so thanks for coming out and staying
around for the whole day I will try to
be on time so we can get to lightning
talks and then to beer provided by coin
sight which we all love I assume there's
gonna be beer but I wasn't told that so
didn't expect it yeah so I'm here
representing them focus but I also where
I have is a chief data scientist at Rex
and dot talked about a little bit about
like what it means to be the head of a
data science team and and being ahead in
the world of data or whatnot
first off kind of talk about how I got
here it's not maybe the most traditional
method but I you know effectively I we
raised a bunch of money X data DARPA and
I think someone else actually talked
about it being very cagey about
commitments you know like my academia
industry I don't know what I want to do
and I would do and then eventually the
startup title inflation racket called me
thanks Travis I think he's over there so
at some point I just became the data
head right so there's no like rhyme or
reason why I was the head at that point
it's just I was leading the project and
so you had to learn on the job like what
is it gonna take to like actually take a
data team to to real goals and in
success and since then I mean I was at
anaconda in the first early early days
leading the data team we let that to
about 50 folks then I went led a company
that was invested by Mark Cuban and we
led to a nice product company of about
10 folks and that one kind of went
pretty well and then now I'm a tracks
which is we're taking a data team
started there were like 30 folks and but
due to data scientists and how about 20
data scientists and about 300 folks so
and over the times I've helped advise
quite a few data teams so over the last
seven years I've been pretty active as a
data head and trying to help people do
these things but I really just kind of
got into it because I was there and I
was I had the hubris to take the title
so if you're thinking about leading like
sometimes just go in and just start
doing it the first thing I would say
kind of to think about to frame this
talk I was kind of how many people have
ever heard
Noah Wasserman's founder dilemmas how
many people have ever seen this book at
one all right
great you all have a 700-page sorry see
you okay all right yeah founder of it
none pilot we've saved it back there
awesome a dilemma find a chair anyways
great book seven order pages so you
don't have time to read it so here it is
in one slide Noah Wasserman went and
analyzed I believe like a hundred and
fifty not data science but companies and
said what are the decision points and a
company what are the things you have to
understand at each decision point and
how do you make those decisions how
other people made those decisions and I
bet I mean he would just love we work
these days there's a lot of like what he
analyzed was on Twitter and like how f
Williams girlfriend owned like a whole
bunch of early things and like now it's
just like oh man you gotta rewrite this
book with we work but he came up with
these kind of four kind of dilemmas or
trade-offs between the relationships
roles rewards and then this kind of like
thing I use our lives like wealth versus
control so you can either have a company
that's going to make money or you can
have a company that you can control
really well and in general you if you
try to make more money you end up
getting a lot less control but you do
end up making more money now companies
like but all others that they give you
the King right and so that's kind of
like the trade-off at every every point
of the career like the career of a
founder is like at what point when you
set up your relationships do you set up
with VCS who are much more money focused
or do you set them up with angels
whoever might who lets you have a lot
more control right do you set it up with
when you go to big I POS do you set up a
board like Facebook or do you set up a
board more like GE I mean there's lots
of like little decisions that kind of
come down to that and so taking that
same kind of framework means like what
happens with your data team we still
have the same like same kind of dilemmas
and things that kind of come in I mean I
think that relationships of roles are
still there and
think somebody's talking about building
your data team and so like the roles of
your data team tomorrow
so super excited about that talk so I
don't have to talk about that too much
here but you're really she's your
paroles now rewards like they're really
talking about money right and and
investment in equity or whatnot
here I think for data teams often it's
around mission like what am I going to
accomplish what am I gonna learn in this
role and like I talked a little about
how we've shaped mission at both of them
focused and Rex and so on the instead
wealth and control I'll say innovation
versus strategy here I think almost
every time I come up with a problem with
the team there's always this kind of do
I stick with the corporate strategy or
the corporate line or do I innovate and
create a new idea and while everybody
hires data scientists like to come up
with ideas they usually constrain to a
box of like what are your operating
procedures and so there's a lot of
learning how to work with those your
business executives and your colleagues
and and what they're what kind of
innovation they're actually willing to
accept I think we kind of hit on some of
that a little bit her talk and so that's
kind of like the framing of of the talk
and so because I'm I'm that kind of guy
I'm not gonna start with number one I'm
gonna jump straight to number three and
come back so let's think about mission
so num focus our mission is to promote
sustainable high-level programming
language open code development and
reproducible scientific research and
that mission is comes up for us to
create a wider wider galaxy of people
who doing reproducible science like our
mission is around science it's not
around necessarily exactly the code it's
not exactly the programming language I
mean we do work in the high-level
programming languages but we also are
here to serve scientists so right away
we tell who we're gonna serve we tell
how we're gonna serve it and then we
work together with the community to make
that happen
how do we were the community educational
programs events fiscal sponsorships and
data and scientific computing community
and so you go to back to the booths and
say like this event right here is part
of the educational program of Pi of the
num focus organization it's getting all
these folks here
I'm talking about all these great
content letting you know Travis pitches
new ideas letting you know learning
about like how galvanizes re revamping
education all these things like happy
because an organization is willing to
come and be the under bone of that and
and raise it to y'all and look at all
the great things you do with it right so
that mission enabled a huge number of
folks to come together in Austin and
collaborate together and that's how
mission and your data team it will work
like your mission will set forth how you
people will come work with you and so
very important I think and you know in
the kind of complete transparency often
um focus as a mission is kind of you
know we've been around for about eight
years and you sometimes it's like oh
we're going to go find funding oh we're
gonna do more community work oh we're
gonna do some crazy project than II
thought up to to make sure everyone's
using Python or our julia but really
that education bringing it back to the
open code principles and actually having
a mission that everyone can contribute
is a very important aspect of building
your your data community so it racks
very similar we come in we say we're
changing the way people's buy and sell
homes so what are we working on buying
and selling homes for a larger number of
people we don't necessarily go back to
just scientists we don't go to a single
group we and we open it up to a very
large audience as that mission really
matters that how you saw how you solve
it one-stop shop caring team lowest
rates and so on and so forth so whenever
you're building your data team it really
matters whether you're in a corporation
you're on a coding team or you're doing
some science how you're gonna actually
get your mission together just to
motivate folks so our mission really
both at num folks and Rex has allowed us
to get more people on the team and go
forward and you have to ask that of your
community whenever you're building your
team why are my folks here what makes
them interested in learning things you
know I think they're people here like
serving in bio and the biotech world
there's I've seen some folks here who
would do the climate change and work
with hurricanes we did a lot of modeling
backwards in academia and
when I start we're going to travellish
we started working with human
trafficking and tracking human
trafficking on the web and things like
that and so there's a huge effect from
this community on the things that we
produce but our underlying kind of goal
is to make it available for everyone to
do these sorts of things so that's sort
of kind of coming at it and
understanding what your mission is and
what's what you can accomplish with your
mission is very important whenever
you're building a team so that's kind of
my first lesson if you get the mission
wrong you're not going to get people to
join you if you get it right you're
gonna find out that people do way more
than you've ever expected so so next
dilemma innovation versus strategy I can
actually explain this a little bit I
think what is innovation so the story I
love about innovation is the the Wright
brothers the Wright Flyer and here you
see the product right everyone kind of
thinks of innovation like the light bulb
the airplane the that maybe some you
know the ledger of the blockchain and
really those are effects of something
else and it's really the effect of an
environment that created a culture that
allowed people to challenge and change
how things happened so whenever you go
read literature about where does
innovation happen you'll see things
people talk about it's like a coral reef
where's a diversity of ideas or where
you know you started in like just like a
very squalid area like it here in the
Wright brothers you see them and I think
this is literally where they they they
did the test and they did that test in
that Shack they lived in that Shack for
like I think it was like six months or
something
and by moving like during the time of
the the when all the like Aeronautics
was blooming and that back in the 1910s
or whatever they there was a lot of
groups like trying to get this but
everyone looked at the Wright brother
and says look those guys moved out to
Kitty Hawk where there's this nice Hill
that they can fly three times a day and
so that innovation that trying over and
over again and moving to an environment
that allowed them to try over over again
that was not a university was not
mandated by HR I mean like they broke
every OSHA rule a possible like a lot of
the things that you you think of an
that make it really great also hinder
your ability to innovate so that's kind
of like my viewpoint of innovation
versus strategy like you still need to
find a way to get your team to innovate
and repeated testing figuring out how to
maybe change a little bit of something
but also you got to pay the price
sometimes of like not a maybe not a nice
facility or maybe not the best paycheck
for six months and so on but the other
side of is like innovation has to come
from everywhere I know personally I
don't believe that you know the the best
ideas come from Western society always
or that it's it's necessarily how fast
you code I think by making a very
inclusive environment you're able to
bring all the all the ideas together and
like let them shake out and and nurture
and learn and so your team really needs
to understand that how do you do that in
a culture can be kind of tough I mean
this is like how do I build policies
that make sure that like you know the
you vote you know folks in a bazaar and
and the Arab world can have the same way
to somebody on the subway in New York
City I mean that's kind of a challenge
here in the you know open source world
oh with the code is open we put it on
the web that means that anybody can
contribute anybody can put things in
there but I guarantee you those children
in a in Africa have no way to interface
with github necessarily so even thinking
beyond just like making it available but
also going out inviting the the right
communities who maybe are they're
underrepresented usually because they
haven't had the right invitations and so
actually building a culture where you
invite people who maybe don't have the
same opportunity as as you did or as
your peers do to participate in that
innovative process at none focus we kind
of put this together and like what I
call the three rules of them focus first
rules build tools or science because
that's our mission we have to go out and
like why we exist is to make science
more effective through scientific tools
be kind to each other
you know racks talked about Connie I
don't know it's a very common thing and
companies I work with
I wonder where people are kind I don't
want to work with people who are jerks
to each other I don't want to work with
people who you know discount my ideas
because I think
to the right school or something like
that right so that that kindness I think
can be you know Mandy in a lot of
different ways I think there's a lot of
fighting about codes of conducts on the
on the web but really what people are
trying to do is just make sure that we
everyone's invited so we can talk to
each other and be kind to each other I
think also in that like you know if I'm
gonna make a decision in the world how
do I tell people that how did I engage
with them to give me back some feedback
to make that decision I think over and
over again early years and then focus we
got told you'd have enough transparency
you don't have enough people telling you
and participating it's like well it's
not like everything we do was open and
everything we did was in minutes on the
website it was on github anything but
there's not transparent and really what
they meant was we don't know how that
decision is being made we don't know why
this has gotten made that way and how we
can interact interface so work really
hard on the projects to say like if you
have a project and you want somebody to
commit to that project you have to tell
them how there can be a committer to
that project it's not like the early
days when you just email Travis and
you're in your code got up into numpy
right you have to have eight you have to
follow the code style you have to there
bug reports have a certain style if you
want an enhancement or a bug like you
have to put it right there in the the
style of the of the bug report or the
the PR and so on and so forth and by
telling people how to participate you're
also giving them a path to innovate so
that innovation can be you can still
capture that spirit of it and a fuse and
some simple rules and third like I think
this probably most controversial for our
organization and then focus is that we
we demand that you lead openly and this
is what kind of I think travel or
Peter's talking about oh s s values next
tomorrow but leading openly is like it's
more than a license it's more than just
making your comments in public it's
really about taking a collaborative
approach to somebody so if I give you
some code you will read that and mate
and if it's good you'll take it in you
won't make me sign and some document
that takes away my rights to for all
sorts of things you won't make me you
won't only accept it in a committee that
doesn't get published there minutes out
or doesn't even
have an opportunity to participate in
you will actually do it in a way that's
open and can the whole community can
contribute to and so that I mean that
that's probably the one of the more like
controversial ideas in like the open
source world I think it's gotten lost I
think early Richard Stallman actually
like try to embody that but then there
are folks who kind of took open source
just I mean like open code and fries
beer and things like that and so you
kind of got muddied and bring that back
we don't necessarily want to take away
people's licensing abilities because it
makes scientists lives harder they can't
use GPL code with code that comes from
somebody else so we prefer permissive
licenses but we really care about that
leading open and making it so your codes
available for others to use and that's
where we want to work with people
similarly like Rex is a company I helped
lead and we did the same sort of thing
we try to here's like directly out of
our core values build out trust fill out
strive for excellence and and really
care about people care about what you're
doing I think like Kim Scott's book a
radical candor has she has like a nice
kind of discussion about why giving a
damn actually is a cultural value and
that you know for us like I like working
at companies to do that so whenever we
build build out our our data team it's
like is this going to be the experience
that helps more people save money is
this going to be the experience that
helps more folks sell their homes faster
better or whatever their their needs are
and of course everyone was to be
excellent so that's a core value so if
we just push each other to be better
every day but then there's also that
trust like be kind to each other and and
take care of each other I mean you have
to push yourselves but you also have to
be kind to each other
so like building that core value that's
really around people and around your
interactions with people really supports
that that idea that we can still
innovate together and move forward and
ultimately I say like you know a
community of innovation I think we're
we're open we're here we're diverse we
try to bring everybody in and I everyone
always ask me who's now focused like
everybody in the room can be part as
part of them focus it's not just the
staff and leaves over here just Lea and
her staff it's like the whole world and
the projects coming together so
come be a part of like all the things we
do and help us innovate okay on the
other side of that was the strategy
right so it's great you want to be nice
to me happy you want to bring open code
in but you still gotta like go you know
you still gotta go take over disrupt
something you still gotta compete
out-compete somebody or things like that
right so you still have to have some
strategy that's gonna make it so you
make your your wins in the data science
world like first up like I kind of just
breaking down like what we do in my
teams typically I try to bring in folks
with domain experience people who are
good at wrangling data folks who have a
lot of modeling experience and and like
some computational experience like so
not only can you you don't get away just
domain expertise or math you have to
have like set of skills and the team has
to round out what we don't have
necessarily and then on top of that I
mean a lot of people think about those
things is like domain expertise and and
and so on I think also about like
reproducibility and communication like
visualizing the result is very important
for your team to get right and so I mean
I used to work at the super commuter
here in town and we had like this whole
room that had like just giant TVs that
you do visualization on and you say why
and like nobody would use it there's no
science value to that like ah but when
Senator Hutchison comes through she goes
in that wall sees how awesome it is so
that communication like was very very
important and communicating that with
necessarily internal teams but those
visualization tools to outside teams I'm
very excited about like panel like
bringing dashboarding to our community
in a faster way I think that's something
that you know we as a community like we
can always be better like getting our
insights to to people that matter I
think what Kevin's talk about that's a
lot like helping them visualize what
their policies are doing and how it's
working is very important so sharing the
stories so I love Jupiter I mean to
Pater's really built as a computational
story and then conda's just to make sure
that people can install these things and
reproduce and do it for us so even
though I think this kind of is the view
of like data science like you know
between computation and and data
wrangling whatnot I think also you have
to think about some of the other aspects
the the share
in your story and making sure people
understand what you're doing so that's
part of the strategy build your team to
get all these different skill sets are
represented then there's like so this is
a great slide from a friend of mine
James Harrison about the platform
strategy and you think about all right I
have all these different skill sets or
codes or different plate ways to work
together and like you have like panel a
over here which is just kind of a
point-to-point whatever you need
whenever you need it kind of strategy
this is really talking about you know
here the way Apple took it is the the
the third panel so the first panel is
kind of chaos if you will but
point-to-point like communication panel
be being like a layered approach we see
this a lot and like architectural books
of like if you want to build a true
architects you need a layer and like the
top layer maybe that's the user layer
doesn't talk to the the bottom layer
which might be your character device I
mean not very many people here have
written the character device code to
their sequel query and I think we're all
happy that we don't have to do that and
so that's kind of a second approach but
then there's like the third Pro choose
the the platform strategy and that's
where you have a core set of
capabilities that in that that's inner
that you can't like services that talk
to that core set or you could have then
that core sets you talked to character
devices or block devices or whatever you
need but all you ever worry about is
that corset and I think that a lot of
like strategies around how you build out
software has work that work very well in
doing that that course platform strategy
I think it applies to your team as well
I think if you have a team like so if
you take of like people and who they
talk to you take a very panel a like
approach where there's like all sorts of
chaos you don't really get as much work
done it's very hard to know if you know
three people are doing the same thing in
this approach right right and panel be
like if you have a hierarchy you get
kind of like the Amazon approach we're
like different folks like you're only in
your bubble or you're only in your
bubble and and it works for a lot of
organizations but then it's hard to jump
over to innovate between each other
whereas like my team's I tend to take
like a platform data team platform if
you will like everybody comes to the
data team and the day
then goes engineering or or other needs
that we may have and we do it as a team
so and our team comes through you know
it's not just coders it's not just
modelers it's a whole variety of folks I
have of an economist I have business
degree folks like running strategy and
it's it's really trying to get the whole
team together to answer the data queries
and actually produce ideas and analysis
so so from a strategy point of view now
deciding like what kind of regulations
and what can happen and who can talk to
who is very important but then you have
to make this actually translate into
like the things we do so technical
strategy like so I talked it was talking
to some executives here in town like a
meet up and they it's like alright so
here's a life cycle I think this is
maybe the least controversial version of
these data science life cycles but so
you have like you know data acquisition
ETL modeling and then like a valuation
and I always kind of you know whether
your data acquisition is like your
Salesforce pipeline or like your web
comments or whatever like there's tons
of different ideas there but once you
acquire the data making it work for your
process I think frictionless data like
shows like all the different problems
that you have buy from data acquisition
to ETL and I think we all love talking
about modeling so I don't have to really
talk too much about that whether it's
deep learning or a psychic learn I mean
but the one thing I think is maybe
something that I over-rotate on is
evaluation so it doesn't matter to me if
you if you have the best model in the
world what matters to me is that
somebody can use that in that model and
make something out of it make it a
better for for somebody in our company
or in our organization I mean that that
part maybe is like I guess it's
appropriate for me to focus on that too
much because if that's not right then
everything else has to be fixed in the
background but you could do this in a
whole different number of ways and if
you're starting a young company like
which going to you pick so here's like
four kind of version this to do data
science right you just do a full custom
code which is where I do all the time
like that like since I grew up coding
and love to code like almost everything
we do together is like full custom code
and all the holes a hole rotating life
cycle but then like frameworks coming
out so just coop flow ml flow and a lot
of these open frameworks that take the
whole lifecycle for you and there's a
lot of great frameworks I think ml flow
is really interesting both of them are
great libraries but you give up some
control right you give up the coop flow
way of doing things or the ml flow way
of doing things so I have to use docker
to use ml flow I don't have to learn
docker right there's all sorts of like
little things you're going to give up or
that you can go to like some sass like
companies like sage maker data studio
there's a whole bunch of like really
great products that can hand handle
almost all of the the lifecycle of data
for you and then off-the-shelf models
like maybe I don't even want do like if
you want to lead an AI company today I
think someone said it just you know
start a company and start advertising in
Google Ads boom you're using AI right
because like Google Ads is all AI driven
right so a lot of us like depend upon
just off-the-shelf models but weird data
scientists so we probably end up some
one of these first three home so you
have to pick kind of like how are you
going to actually build out so if you're
gonna build out a platform and a process
which kind of strategy are you gonna
take full flexibility but maybe you have
to hire more coders no flexibility but
on off-the-shelf models but maybe stuff
stops working you you hope it doesn't
stop working because enough people want
to use it and or to I think where I see
a lot of folks going is either the
framework of the SAS approach and the
SAS approach is being alright you don't
have to hire DevOps you can are just
data scientists right so I don't have to
have nearly as many people but I think
you know going back to that you know
control aspect I like the full custom
codes so the choices I typically make in
almost every data team I've worked with
is the PI data version so yeah I put
juvett in the center because it does
everything I mean Jupiter is its own
force it can it can do everyone every
part of these but it can also be the
thing that shows off what we do use -
quite a bit for running all our data
acquisition whether it's just just
getting data out of AP is and in
Salesforce or running some
calculation on the cluster I mean desk
is great for lots of asynchronous tasks
so pandas all my ETL you move it I think
the every team I've had it's like worked
with numpy and sequel and they moved to
pandas and they're like 10 percent more
effective immediately so just the right
tool for a lot of ETL jobs and like we
use tons of all I put down here psychic
Larry use all sorts of modeling
libraries scikit-learn just it's kind of
a nice representation of everything and
I I don't think I ever have a project
that doesn't go out with a bouquet
dashboard which is why Rex is a sponsor
of bouquet and we we give our money
where our mouth is and say like hey we
wouldn't we just wouldn't be able to
talk to nearly as many of our clients
and the internal company if we didn't
have bouquet on everything and I realize
that some of these stickers are no
longer the same decals here so I'm
definitely go check out the new Panda
sticker and bouquet sticker and so on so
it's always good so that's kind of how
you know I approach strategy in this
like now do I do I let somebody do
anything they want if somebody wanted to
come in and put our into my system yeah
okay we can shop but now you're gonna
have full control you're gonna have to
like learn how to do that pit and maybe
there is a a really cool library and
there are a lot of really cool libraries
out of our but this the the strategy
we've set up doesn't have are in our
core structure so now you're gonna be
responsible for putting that in and
maintaining that and usually people like
oh yeah I can learn Python so okay cool
no have anything as our Julie I love the
languages but the strategy has been set
and it does limit some of the innovation
it's how we have to have to work to get
go forward okay so that's kind of like
you know first where's get mission have
some strategy versus of what what
innovation you're gonna allow then this
next part is like really mushy and I
apologize that it's not as well kind of
understood and I think there's a lot of
discussion every time I go to a
conference I hear a lot about the
different relationships and roles that
data scientist need and have and I don't
have a lot of data here but some more
anecdotes and and how I think about
things so first off like just
understanding like role
of the projects and so there's four kind
of like kind of points I want to kind of
go through this section first it's just
like sustainability of data software and
so as num focus we we see a lot of
projects spin up spin down like aren't
supported anymore maybe they want more
support how do you maintain that and
like even in your company like I think I
saw the chief data scientists of GM get
up and say like half of our data science
projects fail and so they go man like if
half of your investment something fails
like what's going on why is it failing
and go a little bit cats and Hinson or
Dan Katz and Conran hits and have like
some a set of blog posts talking about
this in the context of software and give
a little bit about that then finally the
second is like you have to understand
the economic engine principles around
your whatever you're doing I know like
maybe this is something I didn't think I
would do it's like you know eight years
ago whenever they took that job with
with Travis and continued I was like
modeling the actual business process and
I think it's been said here by somebody
else like if you want to make a lot of
value to your to your company and a lot
of value in the world understand the
economics by which your work is being
used then finally governance of
resources I mean the IRS and SEC like
put a certain restriction on companies
and like some of those restrictions are
good and we can think about that in our
own projects and how how it evolved and
so forth now talk a little bit about the
challenges we have so first and foremost
data science data software
sustainability things break a lot 50% of
projects I would say fail I think it's
probably higher than that and you could
say the same thing with well Andy like
90% of startups fail like that's true
but I think that's people access that
assess that risk and I don't think it's
always a total failure but why are
things failing
Conrad and sorry Conrad Hinson and Dan
Katz make four basic or three basic
points first is that life cycles are
circular and consumptions linear so wait
as you as you build up like your data
science project you you have more needs
for data you have more needs for
modeling and and so you add in more
more teams and more capabilities
throughout throughout your code or
throughout your project or your team but
the consumption of these things is it's
just it's growing linearly so you have
to learn you have to you know if I have
four points in my cycle that I have to
like fill those roles now like I don't
necessarily need the person doing QA or
the evaluation when I'm doing when we
have data acquisition kind of going on
but now I had the data acquisition from
the last time and the data acquisition
for the last time and so as I consume I
see keep on consuming more and more
things so even though my skills are
circular and I I learned at each project
how to be very good at that life cycle
I'm still getting more and more
resources as the the project grows and I
think that a good example is earlier
when Katrina said what's up with that
AWS bill like all of a sudden like this
thing that like ran on you know three
nodes and took a thousand dollars last
month is now we're running in all our
data and it's $40,000 and and then if we
scale it up and run it for the entire
internet it's gonna cost us four million
dollars like if we don't like we don't
like figure that sort of thing out and
so that consumption really puts unfair
barrier on your technology you always
have to think about that the role in the
second point like roles and and I'll
dive into us a little bit more but the
roles and types of infrastructure vary
and it really makes it's it's subtle but
if your roles and your infrastructure
don't really match so for example if I
picked a full custom code but I have no
DevOps talent on my team
then I don't really I can't necessarily
make my software go faster right so I
like I have a team that we used Heroku
for everything and then people wanted to
have a little bit better security
performance so he moved it oh yes but
nobody had ever heard of a Bastion
security hoster or any sort of pairing
of lease concerns between like the
operating cluster and the actual like
control planes or whatnot
and it it just didn't work because you
have to have a lot of security experts
to really maybe hit a PCIe compliance or
a HIPAA compliant type architecture and
so you have to really
think about that very quickly in the
lifecycle of your project and it's
really hard to predict that sometimes
and then there's a tolerance of risk and
like in business if you talk about risk
people understand like what's the risk
of losing money so that that really
translates very well but it also needs
to be proportionate system that's
dependent upon it if I'm risking you
know a script that downloads I don't
know
cats on the internet and that makes no
money like nobody really cares of that
if that system goes down but if it's the
credit card payment system well they
care a lot and so you need to put more
infrastructure around that and so
understanding those trade-offs is very
important for any software project and
especially the data science project
which we often try to innovate we don't
know what those are so to give you kind
of an idea of like like the
infrastructure varying or whatnot
we usually so Hynson give hints and cats
give this kind of like comparison to a
city infrastructure so you can imagine a
slum that has lots of units and arguably
should be torn down frequently because
the they don't maintain like proper
maybe proper hygiene or other things
like that you could also think of like a
residential home which has a solid
foundation for at least 25 years even
though we try to lead them for 50 we can
here in Austin you have like sandy soil
and they they kind of crack right so but
it only services a single family so if
it goes away like it's tragic for a
single family but it's not tragic for
the entire community and so we have
services we hope to to help those folks
then you have residential apartments
such as like large structures serving 5
to 100 years you know like this building
here didn't exist 50 years ago but we do
expect it to be here 50 years from now
and it's gonna have you know dozens of
companies and and hundreds of people
coming to it every day and so if the
toilets go out here I guarantee you is a
bigger problem that goes out at your
home so like understanding the risk and
then you have city infrastructure that
just must never fail if it fails I mean
we hope that you know politicians change
change tenure and things like that
although Flint Michigan might not might
prove otherwise on that so in that same
way how does that go to software
infrastructure India
so if all you're doing is a research
paper you know you have fewer results a
year very few upstream dependencies very
nice like come give a party to talk
about it if it doesn't exist beyond this
alright great
you innovated you had an effect and you
throw it over and it might catch fire it
might not but at the other day we don't
need to support that anymore there's
like a group code like so maybe you have
a like my group right now at wrecks we
have they we had 50 different reports we
gave a little last year and so it's
services are our code that builds on it
services our group we don't have to put
it out it makes it very easy to support
very easy to maintain and we don't
really need like all the burden of the
community looking at it and doing PRS
and and all the maybe policies that you
would have like an enum PI codebase or
something oh and so that's a really
great level to like be at for inside
your inside your company
you think about it there but then
there's like pandas and numpy which
service hundreds of people and hundreds
of results and so now you need an
organization like them focus something
that is going to help them work together
and have rules for governance and being
able to understand each other's results
but also share very easily and and make
things go faster and we all depend upon
these domain libraries the same as your
team is going to depend upon HR or maybe
other like companies like you and so on
so thinking about that infrastructure in
your company your group and your code
and then there's like platform like I
think it was likely our OS of like Apple
just stopped mate stop shipping with
Python we have some we'd have some
awards right it would be a real problem
in crisis in our community we'd have to
go figure out so but right now like it's
pretty safe bet that Python and Mac's
are still going to work together I mean
they they depend upon us we depend upon
them so those are kind of like variants
of like the infrastructure that you have
to think about in the relationship and
how you're building out your roles now
the economic engine like iLike Goldratt
every every organization has a goal the
goal is to maximize something while
minimizing some Cal's linear bevery
linear programming book go look up
Goldratt go the goal and it's like him
teaching business people how to do
linear programming all right so here's
your your your maximize your
sold while minimizing your operational
expenses in your inventory and like I
think it was in the nineties when this
came out and it was like revolutionary
to think that actually your your
inventories an asset I mean it was
thought of as an asset by accountants
but it's actually a debt because you
have that inventory it you no longer
have the permission to innovate because
you have to like process that inventory
you know think of the same thing in you
know research or data Sciences you know
maximizing credit for the things you do
but also you know your operation
minimizing like the number of
operational techniques you have to do or
memorizing the governance or the
resources you have to manage so if I
have to manage thousands of bug requests
like I'm not gonna give any features
done all right I'm not going to get much
credit for the newest feature so
understanding how your team can minimize
the the burden on what they do while
maximizing their credit is very
important now how does that relate to
who we are and what we do well I play
out like there's four different types of
people in an unfocused world I say
there's intellectuals like a professor
in a university there's technical
crafters principal engineers at
companies or communal motivators like
your product managers or or Community
Managers inside the community and then
there's folks who are you know
entrepreneurs who really want to go out
and get that economic engine rolling and
make it making more money for the
company thinking about them each point
is going to have a different economic
engine intellectuals want citations they
need citations in order to keep tenure
they need citations to keep doing what
they're doing and they're gonna get
resources from federal research grants
normally and they generally use scholars
a scholarly research and how many people
are in a data science team that actually
reads reads papers every week or every
month or so yeah so see we all use these
folks we love them and it's in the more
we can give them credit for what they do
the more ideas that can give us so
that's a really great economic engine
that we can participate in and your
group can participate in all right I've
never been upset about giving like
working with an intellectual group like
at a university and giving some you know
even giving them Pizza money sometimes
like figuring out how to have a
relationship where you just go talk to
them once a year or have
come give presentations helps like the
the entire that both us and them so I
think that that's always something every
group I've ever worked with we've done a
lot with intellectuals that whether
universities or think tanks or labs or
whatever the second is crafters you know
I think this you know like you look at
guys like sorry Peter or Peter Wang
who's a bouquet of Travis who's a numpy
West McKinney who wrote pandas these
folks they really really love doing
great software and you talk to them I
mean they will get into the nitty-gritty
about exactly what you know like we just
heard off 45 minute ago to you alright
which I guarantee like you hopefully
never have to touch write like me and my
role like I hope I never have to touch
dude you Rea again but I'm absolutely
excited that Travis is gonna go down and
make sure it's extensible for everybody
so like it can solve all sorts of goals
for us and today like usually what is
kind of happening is we we give them
praise companies give them highly paid
positions and they do a lot of software
development right or research or
something that is a tangible thing
they're crafting then there's like
stewards I think of for example Lee over
here who really worries about the
community health builds these
organizations to maximize the number of
people can come together and talk to
each other and understand each other and
can keep this innovation working and so
a lot of like I mean how this works is a
lot of private donations some public
public grants here and there and but
it's a lot of goodwill I mean I think
that the fact that you're here and
you're happy to be here and you think
the people who made this happen keeps it
keeps them energized and keeps them in
it doing it over and over again and so
give lots of love to your community
managers and and realize who those are
in any team you have whether or not it's
I've never gone on a date with you they
didn't have a champion at an executive
level or somewhere else and then
entrepreneurs yeah we're the money
grubbers like that I'll confess to that
like you know I go talk to investors all
the time and I really care about making
sure that the business works very well
you don't have to serve them like
they'll deserve themselves so
so running I mean so thinking about that
like maybe I'll skip over some of the
government resources but you can think
of this the same idea like how do i cure
this how do we govern our resources and
so forth to kind of finish up like you
know some of the challenges around the
relationships and roles that you have to
think about is like what time energy
structures are we supporting you know
now focus chosen scientists quit our
mission dictated sciences we work on
open code so that gives us like the
infrastructure we need it doesn't makes
much sense for us to run a lot of hey we
have services because a lot of the
libraries we support are on your laptops
and for us to like take over the service
would be just a waste of our time and it
probably efforts and when it's much more
effective on your laptops for example
the same thing as science science
usually goes for groups and researchers
companies usually like the focus is like
how do I help the consumer and so you
need to build those services so the
consumer never has to think about
software things like that and also you
have to think about like these different
economic engines between the different
roles you have and the goals are not
aligned but the more you can think about
as I bring in those people into your
team and help them achieve their goals
the more everyone's gonna like like
working together and they're gonna be
kinder to each other and everyone's
going to actually get to that innovation
much faster with that said it's the end
of my talk is like the relationships
careers and resource contentions very
matter a lot roles it's always varied an
evolving a definitely go to the data
teams talk tomorrow I think that's going
to be really great to hear about
experience of building teams but member
your mission is critical work because
it's going to define those roles in
relationship and then figuring out how
to make sure your team can still have
strategies but also allow innovation
thank you very much
[Applause]
we have time for a question or you might
have a question yes so the question is
thinking back on my experience was the
the worst decision I made and what's the
best decision I made yeah I think the
worst decision okay the best decision
let's see I think the best decision is
to celebrate wins actually like folks
here at anaconda like everyone still
comes up to me and says I and II like
demo Friday was awesome this week I wish
you were there it was just a way to like
make sure like everybody had a spot to
talk about the wins and like it's like
oh yeah I helped you guys raise like
tens of millions of dollars and helps
you get to like I don't really know a
company but like the only thing you
remember is the demo day Friday awesome
so so bring like very successful wins
and the worst thing I think the worst
thing has always been when I put myself
over my people
whenever there's you know I want to go
this conference so I'm not gonna sit
here and listen to like the review or I
have you know I don't have time to like
actually meet with you every day you're
like a good example is Andy grows high
high performance output management and
something like those those words are in
the title I'm nicer than that order I'm
gonna border if you haven't probably if
you ever heard but in there he talks a
lot about one-on-ones and how to take
care of your folks right and like that
like in some sense like creating like
knowledge management and and caring for
the people who are working for he's like
the most important aspect of being a
head of anything
and so there's often times I put my own
needs in front of those folks and I
think they've always kind of hurt me in
some way or the other so I don't have a
single one but that's generally what it
is
oh Christ what's demo day Friday so in
this actually I stole this from parsley
from Andrew a parsley so it's not like
my idea or anything but the idea being
that you're in a group you're in a
company you're in some tribe but
everyone has something to do like give
people the opportunity praise like we're
gonna do lightning talks right here and
lightning talks are an easy way for
people to like come up and give a talk
about something that they're passionate
about without a lot of commitment so our
demo day Friday it was like tell us
something you you you found interesting
or something you built or something you
can demo that that makes people happy
about it and it really the fact that it
was there on the Friday and it was at
lunch and like it was easy to go to and
we we invited everybody and the company
to come to it meant that like you had
permission to like be playful this one
hour of the week right and so people got
to look forward to it's like not only
did I like fix some bug in like some
kubernetes code because like gee gee
buff protocol didn't work that like
nobody in the world is gonna care about
this one hour I get it gum talked about
and people will give me some praise so
that notion of like sharing a very
technical deep way and in a very easy
way like in this way we have lightning
talks at every event is so that there's
always an easy way to come in and give a
give a presentation that would not one
more
well thank you Andy appreciate it
[Applause]